30 uhr kommen sollen videowall laser und
die spitäler wenn ich zur um eine
misslungene was wir machen wollten wir
das spiel hast du vor darauf gespielt
haben lügen oder nicht liege oder
sonst ja ich habe lukas
in meiner hand
hörst du
hörst du hast du das spiel verstanden
was sagen was zu haben ich habe meiner
hand ein etui
energie
ja mach mal auf mit reißverschluss
[Musik]
habe es ist in lauter
habe es sandra
ich lauter und die was drinnen werden
problem nicht ja das problem
dass kaputt man was das der aufschrift
ich doch gesagt leider kommt noch nie
gesagt ich meine
ok sandra ich habe hier einen
tischtennisschläger kann zu dem vorfall
lassen
kannst du den mal wirklich so schräg wie
immer offen
du hast nicht
ich habe in meiner hand luca ein
glasreiniger
glasreiniger auf den tisch mit einem
mache ich
das richtig
so habe ich hier in meiner hand wenn ich
jeden tag so sanft starten ein
furzkissen
kurzes erholt ich habe ihn rausgenommen
nein doch nein doch habe ich es kann
nicht verkürzen dank sie mal anfassen
sandra nicht
ich habe in der hand ein
perfekt offen ja
okay was steht da drauf
ok und wie viel mittel des theaters
30 30 0 sparfuchs ist das aus
glasverpackung jo hoffen auf den tisch
und die hat spuren war dann die luft
was für mich
[Applaus]
ok sandra ich habe jeden seiner hand ein
furzkissen
mache es an ist dann kannst du kannst
auf dem tisch ja
kannst es noch mal und noch
mal
kannst du mal so darauf tippen mit dem
finger
ja das furzkissen
mini kurz
luca
zunächst etwas schnee
ich habe in meiner hand ein
sd-kartenslot ding ein sd-kartenslot
oder eine sd karte ein sd-kartenslot
wenn es besonders
großen auf den tisch mit der us-seite
ja falsch ich hab's sd karte
sala ich halte in der hand wunderschönes
merchandise kosten gekommen dass shop.de
ja hast du mein eigener boss und kleiner
pisser bierkönig die
who
ich halte in meiner hand mal wieder ein
paar fällen schon wieder
was sie draufhaben
in die luft
flog wurden
falls es ist alles offen
wissen sie das
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so sandra ich halte in der hand mich
wie mich weil ich der hammer wenn
du hast jetzt haben der andere nicht ich
habe ein hammer also mich kannst du dir
du kannst ja nicht ich selber halten
oder mal so ich bin einfach der hammer
nicht
so ruhig
ich versteh ich das team hat in der
firma aber du bist ja denn du denkst
dass du dir haben aber wer deswegen habe
ich mich in der hand ich noch einmal
gelernt
hast jetzt gegenstand haben nein
ich habe hier immer das hört ja ein
bisschen habe auch keinen richtigen
anderes in falsche hände
und winkte
ja
muss man mal 100 christen und ich noch
so viel an kuka ich habe in meiner hand
ja
was
grösser oder bürgers luca ich hatte in
meiner hand eine dose oder ertrinken aus
der dose
ok
[Musik]
hab ich gemacht nein
horst klose ich hab einfach
als nächstes produkt habe ich hier
bambus kohle
natürliche
luftbefeuchter die man in die schuhe
packen kann so dass die schuhe so ein
bisschen den geruch verlieren ist die
marke die marke heißt
die mio und was sagen dass all das sind
so kleine kissen die packst du deine
schuhe unternehmen die ehre buch an
und da ständig sie auch weil deine füße
stinkt immer wie die pest entwickelt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich habe in meiner hand
ein polaroid welt was oft betroffen ich
uns über
jeden tag sein unterkiefer
ausgestopft schon oder
sehrbrock dafür sagte wehren aus stoffen
menschen hast du selbst gesagt kann ich
das bezeugen
man sieht nicht nur ins ich habe kannst
nochmals party feiert und slapstick und
du mit deinem viele aber das bild
[Musik]
ja hast du nicht
hast du nicht
letztes produkt von mir auch sandra ich
habe hier nämlich kann stellen dafür was
benutzte die 46 ich bin polizist doch
mal gewähren dann
kann mit beiden händen die ringe und
gestoßen war dagegen
wie stoßen du kannst eine hand hin dass
einer kennt diesen greifen die anderen
beschlüsse dagegen für golfer
hast du
das nächste mal mit uns
zusammenschließen nein nicht das heutige
wieder sauber halten meine lieben
freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat das
gerne einen daumen hoch oder dem video
hier da aber wir brechen hat und klickt
auf die glocke der weitere wehren mit
besser videos nicht verpassen wollte
nicht gerade selbstverständlich nicht
der beschreibung verlegt und du hast
auch die letzten vier wörter ich will
dich
deine logik berichten
weiß nicht wie das geht
zum glück hielt dieses jahr